new news on CD projekt red's transition
from a fantasy world of sword and spell
slinging to the Future of flying cars
with ladies for sizer arms I'm Dave and
welcome to your gamespot news update the
witcher 3 wild hunt developer CD Projekt
RED now wants to publish its next game
cyberpunk 2077 in late 2016 according to
a new report cyberpunk 2077 was
announced in October 2012 and at the
time CD Projekt RED said it was not
planning to discuss the game until 2017
at the earliest however citing a source
close to the studio game reactor Germany
reports it now and staying for a late
2016 launch as of yet CD Projekt RED has
not officially announced a release date
or period itself although the game is
currently only set 4pc the unnamed
source claims a playstation 4 and xbox
one release is more than likely person
goes on to say the either Sony or
Microsoft may try to secure the game as
an exclusive title on December 5th the
studio said it's focusing on cyberpunk
2077 but intends to continue supporting
its award-winning Witcher 3 with new
content the game second paid expansion
blood and wine comes out in 2016
although details about the game have
been few and far between studios joint
c.e.o adam Kaczynski has said that the
game is even more ambitious than what
the developer had originally had in mind
are you excited about CD projekt red's
next big release are you still enjoying
your adventures through the witcher 3
let us know in the comments section
below or you can find me on Twitter at a
regular Dave and for all your Witcher
and cyberpunk news make sure to stay
tuned to gamespot com
you